the story and now to a story that's
enraging as it is chilling one week ago
a man named alexis sabaret
of shakopee minnesota was arrested after
beheading a woman in broad daylight
now this heinous crime would surely be
national news
what was the motive who was this man did
he have any criminal background
was he an american citizen now all of
those questions remained
obscured not worthy of examination until
one minnesota attorney and blogger
started digging
now scott johnson of the popular
powerline blog joins me now
scott um tell us what you learned and
why
others seemed kind of disinterested in
this
shocking and grisly story
laura it's really a heartbreaking and
enraging story as you suggest
and i've been working on it for the past
week
he the savart just made an initial
appearance on the murder charge
this past friday and
in the course of that hearing in the
initial appearance
he said he wanted to be deported to his
country that got my attention
the fact that this beheading occurred in
broad daylight
in the leafy suburb uh twin cities
suburb of shakopee minnesota
on a residential street got my attention
and unbelievably
he was at the time he beheaded his
girlfriend
america thayer a legal
immigrant citizen of the united states
who changed her name to america when she
became a citizen
he was on his way to court on an
underlying arson crime
three felonies incredibly violent that
also involved the use of the machete
that he used to be head
america thayer uh on his way to court
this past
uh wednesday a week ago wednesday so it
those things taken together are just
unbelievable
have we ever had a public beheading in
broad daylight
in minnesota i don't think so and and he
his immigration status is what how did
it get into the country
he came uh he entered
he's a cuban illegal immigrant he
entered
uh through el paso in 2007
and uh by 2012 there were two
deportation orders that he had racked up
and ice was ice was not able to deport
him
because cuba wouldn't take him back so
we've been stuck with them and the guy
has been a one-man crime wave
beating up women and and committing
crimes uh for the past 10 years
well we can look forward to more grisly
crimes given what's happened
at the border uh over the last six
months uh this is
thank you for doing this digging no one
else did it scott thank you hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else